[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing
the founders of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
godric gryffindor salazar satherin helga
hufflepuff
and rowena ravenclaw more specifically
however we're going to be looking at the
founders in the context of
their power in the past i've ranked the
most powerful slytherins gryffindors
hufflepuffs ravenclaws order of the
phoenix members
dumbledore's army members auras death
eaters
weasleys and more so i thought it only
natural
that next we rank the founding members
of each of the hogwarts houses
now before we get things rolling i just
want to say one thing
all four of the hogwarts founders were
immensely powerful
and i mean powerful in fact the level of
power
the founders possessed is thought to be
uncomparable to
most modern day witches and wizards
uncomparable is a strong word
and suggests that they were eons ahead
of the wizards of today
but why they were so powerful is
uncertain and i wonder
if it's just that the power of witches
and wizards has been watered
down over time if not what made them so
special
why were they so skilled in my eyes i
would assume
that the magical beings of the wizarding
world would only become
more powerful as a whole over time
learning
new spells and tricks from their
ancestors however
it seems to be quite the opposite in
fact the most powerful witch and wizard
to have ever existed also lived during
the time period that the hogwarts
founders were around
the most powerful wizard was merlin a
wizard that appears in both harry potter
folklore
and our own folklore centuries after his
demise
merlin was immortalized in the form of a
chocolate frog card
praised for his robust knowledge of
magical abilities
on the other side of things we have
morgana leffe merlin's nemesis
in some versions of folklore a powerful
witch and accomplished animagus
that was also immortalized on her own
chocolate frog card
a bit about the history of the founders
in the 10th century
the hogwarts founders the original house
members got together and established
that they hand
the self-same yearning to make the
world's best magic school
their collective agreement that the
wizarding world was in need of a good
strong magical school resulted in the
birth of hogwarts
which was built somewhere off hidden in
the scottish highlands
each of the founders were immensely
powerful and contributed to the birth of
hogwarts in their own unique way
but what i want to explore in this video
is who was the
most powerful founder it would be all
nice and fun to assume
that they were all equal but that's not
realistic
so sit back relax and enjoy my own
personal rankings of the hogwarts
founders
this is entirely subjective so comment
your own rankings down below
then play the video and see if yours
line up with mine
number 4 helga hufflepuff we don't
actually have a lot of information on
helga
but what we do know is that the founders
of hogwarts all four of them
were immensely powerful hailing from the
valleys of wales
helga hufflepuff was a round plump woman
with brown hair and blue eyes
she was most likely a pure blood witch
and had a bit of a different approach to
teaching students
from the other founders where the other
founders valued traits like ambition
bravery and intelligence helga was
willing to take in
anyone i'll teach the lot and treat them
just the same
she didn't have the same elitist
mentality that some of the other
founders had
and just wanted students to be educated
regardless of where they were sorted
in terms of the founders there seems to
be the least information out there on
helga
but one thing that is reinforced over
and over again
is her kind fair nature don't get me
wrong
she was talented in fact she was
particularly talented at producing
charms
especially food related charms she
assisted in enchanting the sorting hat
and used her charm work to help feed the
students of hogwarts
though i'm sure she was capable of much
more we also know that hufflepuff was
capable
of producing a patronus charm since
hufflepuff was the most easy going
she was definitely the least preoccupied
with dueling or being powerful
and for this reason she is number four
on the list number three
rowena ravenclaw coming in at number
three on the list
is rowena ravenclaw the original
ravenclaw
rowena was born sometime in the 10th
century in scotland
and was a close friend of fellow founder
helga hufflepuff
who was from wales there is much
speculation that both the location and
name of hogwarts were chosen by rowena
who dreamt that a warty hog was leading
her to a cliff
by the lake she also came up with the
ever-changing floor plan
rowena ravenclaw was thought to be the
most brilliant witch of her time
and it suggested that she was more
powerful than helga hufflepuff
powerful witch and fellow founder unlike
helga rowena was more versed in a
multitude of magical capabilities
and though she wasn't particularly
skilled at food-related charms
she was a skilled practitioner of charms
in her own right
in fact rowena even enchanted her own
diadem
advanced magic that caused the diadem to
enhance the wearer's wisdom
rowena like helga was also able to
produce a patronus
and it has been expressed that she was
even versed in divination
which is a skill reserved for very few
witches and wizards
ravenclaw was a spectacle she was an
absolute genius and she had a studious
nature
setting the precedent for the students
of ravenclaw house
however despite all of her knowledge i
doubt that she was the most powerful of
the founders
as like helga she was not particularly
preoccupied with pursuing power
or being the best duelist one thing that
ravenclaw
can certainly claim however is that
during her lifetime
she was likely the most knowledgeable
magical being
around number 2 godric gryffindor
this is where things start to get tricky
because you see gryffindor and slytherin
were both astonishingly powerful
just in different ways godric was a tall
muscular man with a lion-like mane of
hair
this is representative of the gryffindor
crest which contains a line
gryffindor was unusual as a wizard in
that he would often duel with a sword
rather than with a wand this was to give
people a fighting chance
he was an extremely impressive swordsman
in fact rolling said it herself
gryffindor was the most accomplished
duelist of his time
however i want to make a distinction
here being a powerful duelist
does not automatically give you the top
spot for power
particularly as his title most likely
pertains to his swordsmanship
and his ability to win sword fighting
duels not necessarily
magic based jewels with that being said
however
godric was still suited to martial magic
in addition to being an impressive
swordsman and duelist
godric was also a charms master and the
original owner of the sorting hat
he was a great man and a strong advocate
for muggle-born acceptance
his big heart is unquestionably one of
the ranking factors here especially
given the importance
that the harry potter story has placed
on love and the power that love holds
number one salazar slytherin last but
not least we have salazar satherin
the father of slytherin and voldemort's
ancestor
slytherin was a pureblood wizard that
was born sometime
before 976 a.d and he was infamous for
having the least tolerant view
towards muggles and mongol-born students
his legacy
is certainly not one that beams with
positivity and he even left the school
because he couldn't agree with how the
other founders operated he wanted only
pureblood students at the school
and passed on this philosophy to his
students when he saw that things weren't
going to go his way he built the chamber
of secrets
a secret chamber which contained a
powerful basilisk
intended to rid the school of
muggleborns the most impressive part of
this
however was that he created the basilisk
himself
basilisks are no joke in fact they are
one of the most powerful creatures in
the wizarding world
so the fact that he was able to create
one and hide it
right under the noses of the other
founders is nothing short of impressive
because slytherin was the only founder
to pursue the dark arts in any capacity
his magical arsenal was considerably
larger than the other founders
he did things with magic that other
morally righteous wizards
were too noble to do but salazar had no
shame
just like voldemort because of this he
became exceptionally skilled at
producing dark magic
not only that but he was a master
legitimate skilled wand maker
and charms expert i think that however
you order this list
everyone is going to be reasonably close
particularly the top two
godric and salazar who i think are in
immediate contention for the top spot
what do you guys think what's your order
let me know in the comments section
below until next time never tickle a
sleeping dragon